[Música]
hasta que todo muy buenos días gracias
por venir a esta charla ted y bueno yo
soy un emprendedor de la zona tengo
tengo actualmente 25 años y quiero
partir haciendo una pregunta que es que
es el emprendimiento para ustedes y que
es la pasión
normalmente la gente piensa que
emprender significa que voy a ganar
dinero emprender para la gente
que voy a dejar de lado tener un jefe y
partir por mis propias herramientas pero
emprender es mucho más que eso en mi
caso y por mi historia de día para mí
emprender significó ganarle a la vida
fue recibir mi historia fue atreverme a
salir del común de lo que tenía
predestinado para mi destino y atreverme
a ir un poquito más allá a pesar de que
todas las condiciones las pocas
condiciones que tenía abrazo y adelante
las tomé la ocupe mi favor y dije ok voy
a hacer lo que me gusta
voy a salir adelante y hoy a ganarle a
la vida
quiero contarle un poquito de mi
historia y mi historia aparte de mi
historia es verdad bastante complicada
nosotros con mi hermano nacimos un hogar
un poco
un poco difícil principalmente porque mi
padre de largo camino no logró controlar
su adicción y debido a esto
mi madre se separó de él para poder
salvar este entorno dañino que podría
afectarnos y que podía un poco
y en contra de todo lo que mi madre
quería para nosotros es por esto que
cuando teníamos ocho años mi abuelos
paternos echaron de la casa mi mamá eso
significó que tuvimos que ir a vivir de
llegado a la casa mi abuela y en una
pieza de tres por tres dormíamos cinco
personas y así fue como parte de mi
historia de vida
con dificultades con un padre que no fue
padre y con una madre que supo a pesar
de las adversidades de su situación y de
todos los malos que teníamos encima
apoyarnos y que era nuestro objetivo y
sueño
yo me considero un emprendedor pero no
un emprendedor porque hoy en día tengo
una empresa o porque tengo un negocio
sino porque logré ganarle a la vida
porque todos mis días resulta que yo me
analizo hoy en día digo que si soy un
emprendedor pero no un emprendedor
solamente por el negocio sino que soy un
emprendedor porque supe de cada cosa
sacarla adelante cuando tenía un chico
cuando tenía ocho años escondía ya más
los días martes y hoy viendo el pasillo
en bulgaria con finlandia llegaba a la
vega entonces resulta que yo llegaba a
la vega y como ya trabajaba todo el día
salí a escondidas de la casa y empezaba
a cuidar auto eso significó que cuidaba
auto para un poco de dinero no mucho
pero que eran como dos mil pesos al día
pero me servía para tener dinero para
comprarme dulces como todo un niño uno
quiere comprarse dulces ok yo quería
ganar mi propio dinero porque sabía que
mi mamá no me va a dar dinero porque no
había dinero en la casa con suerte
teníamos dinero para poder sobrevivir
entonces junta dos mil pesos esos dos
mil pesos de la semana se convertían en
cuatro mil pesos cuatro mil se
convertirá en seis mil y resulta después
de cinco semanas ya tenían diez mil
pesos me muero con ocho años imagino que
lo que recuerda en su tiempo lo que
significa
de mil pesos a 18 años entonces yo ya
sabía lo que es ganar mi dinero luego de
eso toda la vida seguía adelante ganaba
dinero como podía vendí algunas cosas y
así me vayan generando para poder
sobrevivir y para poder también no
depender o no quejarme frente a lo que
significaba no tener dinero es por esto
que a los 15 años dentro de mí de mi de
mi ganas de salir adelante y estaba
haciendo deporte yo siempre ocupó las
herramientas del deporte para
mantenernos alejados del entorno que nos
movíamos en hualpencillo es un sector
vulnerable donde se presenta mucho la
delincuencia hay temas de droga y
nosotros ya veníamos de un entorno donde
veíamos a diario la drogadicción de por
parte mía baja entonces nos miraba como
la idea de que como ayudo a mis hijos y
entonces se la escribí la idea que que
fue un poco en contra de la corriente
que fue sino que los voy a voy a hacer
que me constan deportistas y entonces el
deporte les va a tragar herramientas
para poder empoderarse frente a la vida
dentro de este concepto mi hermano ya
era gimnasta en la era selección
nacional y yo había pasado por al menos
78 deportes siempre medidas en torno a
poder buscar nuevas cosas no nunca me
conforme con nada era como dizzy
gimnasia luego atletismo luego voleibol
handball capoeira de todo hasta que
conozco el levantamiento olímpico de
pesas y resulta que después de un año
encuentro aquí ok me encanta esto me
encanta
quiero ser levantador de pesas pero no
quería ser cualquier doctor de meses no
quería ser el mejor de chile y eso
significaba que para hacer el mejor de
chile yo tenía que estar en la selección
nacional de levantamiento olímpico peso
acto seguido a los 16 años estaba en un
campeonato y estaba jaime tura que uno
lo mejor de levantadores olímpico de
chile junto a su entrenador uno del otro
gran nacional yo me acerco y le digo
víctor rubilar se llama el elantra
ordenación le digo
si yo me voy a sentir usted me entrega
y él me dice sí obvio yo tenía 16 años
acto seguido es un domingo el lunes le
digo a mi mamá mamá me voy a ir a
santiago
mi mamá me irónico pero no me dijo nada
su cara lo dijo todo fue como que está
hablando 16 años pero no me creían
importe yo jueves y al móvil maleta mi
mano está en la casa llega la nueva
noche digo mamá me voy a dejar terminal
y su cara pálida
pero el colegio no ya me retiré del
colegio yo me he arreglado el colegio yo
mismo me retiro del colegio dije quiero
ser deportista no quiero estudiar porque
no lo que me llena no lo que me apasiona
quiero dedicarme al deporte y ser un
deporte olímpico darle una medalla me
veis este es mi objetivo en ese momento
yo me imaginaba en un podio con cantando
el himno nacional y recibiendo una
medalla para el país así que no fue
dejar los bordes que nunca habían dado
metro más santiago nunca ha salida sólo
y llegó a las 12 de la noche a el
terminal
sólo con 16 años llegó mi maleta y tenía
que irme a quinta normal quinta normal
de una comuna un poco de escaso recurso
entre comillas en santiago y tenía que
llegar a un sector súper vulnerable
me acuerdo que tomé una micro con suerte
salí a la estaba justo el tema nuevo del
transantiago y llegó llegó la casa del
amigo mi hermano
y ahí viví durante un año todos los días
tenía que tomar la 506 que se muera 90
minutos y me lleva al centro de alto
rendimiento y ahí pasaba todo mi día
entrenando muchas veces fue difícil
porque como no tenía los recursos para
poder mantenerme santiago era de partido
alto rendimiento entrenaba 2-3 veces al
día pero mi almuerzo eran para confites
con pollo una población de mil 500 pesos
y otras veces me hicieran forzada
hubieron semanas que solamente comía
huevo y avena porque no tenía dinero
para más pero yo subía que es también en
ese momento no era malo no era bueno
eran las condiciones que tenía para
poder salir adelante y estaba dispuesto
a todo a todo por lograr lo que quería
luego de eso sigo avanzando sigo
avanzando a los 17 encuentra una nueva
forma de hacer dinero para mantener
media en la selección no entregaron su
elemento y esos suplementos mis
compañeros no sólo tomaban y yo como era
medio inteligente y han tenido un poco
el concepto del negocio digo ok
este complemento resulta que esos
elementos que estaban 40 mil pesos y eso
lo compran a mi amigo a 10 mil pesos y
lo revendía 30 mil y me queda de
convertir mil pesos para el bolsillo y
así vas juntando dinero sobrevivir y
seguir adelante y pasaban meses meses
meses meses hasta que después de tres
años entrenar dos mil euros logró ser
campeón nacional juvenil y adulto con 19
años le haya ganado a todos en chile
logre ese objetivo día hasta ese momento
por temas audios del deporte y lo que
todos sabemos que pasan chile tengo que
retirarme tuve que tuvo que llegar al
momento de tomar una decisión sigo
siendo el procesal de rendimiento o
busco alguna otra forma como poder
ganarle a la vida porque sabía que en
algún momento esta carrera se iba a
acabar no ya lograría que al mes y nada
porque un deportista de alto rendimiento
en verdad en chino no tiene las
condiciones para poder vivir del deporte
y mi entrenador que era un cubano en ese
momento me dice se me dice marcelo sabes
que yo me voy a chile
entonces vamos a analizar y digo esta es
mi pasión este mi sueño pero hay algo
más importante en la vida que mi familia
y yo siempre me fui con la mente muy
clara en que no podía solamente quedarme
con mis propios objetivos y solamente
pensar en yo sino que tenía que pensar
en mi familia porque significa y yo
sabía que mi mamá era una profesora que
su sueldo en algún momento no le iba a
dar para vivir toda su vida bien y que
se iba a jubilar y que la jubilación del
profesor no es buena entonces sabía que
tenía que tomar las riendas de mi vida
para poder en algún momento ayudarla y
volver en la mano por todo lo que he
hecho así que dentro este concepto y
digo que me voy a retirar de la
selección vuelve a construcción y llegó
con 19 años de concepción
y resulta que analizó la situación yo
siempre soy muy analista en cuanto a las
posibilidades que tengo que salir
adelante o posibilidades algún proyecto
o posibilidades de de cómo empoderar me
encanta la vida
digo que puedo hacer estudiar no estaba
dentro de mis opciones porque los
recursos no me alcanzaban para estudiar
así que en base a eso empecé a trabajar
así clases de levantamiento olímpico en
un gimnasio de cross fit no se publica
lo que creo que es un sistema de
tratamiento funcional que busca gimnasia
del mismo y así va mezclando varias
cosas y espacios en clase y resulta que
nos di cuenta que era bueno en lo que
hacía lograba entregar el mensaje a la
gente de entrenar mantenerte saludable
luchar por todo quería y aparte era muy
era muy didáctico y metodólogo en cuanto
a cómo realizar las clases de
entrenamiento a la gente le empezó a
gustar trabajar en un gimnasio que yo
estaba en san pedro y dure dos meses en
ese proyecto luego de eso dejé de
trabajar ahí y empecé a avanzar ya que
voy a hacer néstor generar dinero porque
mi sueño era mi familia no pudo ser así
tenía 19 años pero ya tenía claro el
cuento de que no podía así estar llegar
a la casi semana también 2000 peso
porque necesito ir a no se compran algo
no dame 10 mil pesos porque quiero a
carretear con mi amigo no nunca fue la
mentalidad yo de los 19 ya quería
trabajar quería luchar por mi objetivo
quería hacer crecer algún negocio
yo quería ser el campeón del mundo lo
que hacía avanzar nunca me conformado
por poco nunca creo que porque yo había
en concepción no puedo pensar en muy
grande así que pasa esto yo digo ok
como emprendo un negocio y hoy converso
en un día con mi imagen me dice pero por
qué no haces un gimnasio
con qué dinero con suerte teníamos para
comer
y resulta que me dice pero
yo vi a un préstamo y el amigo mamá está
en dicom no puedes mi persona
la realidad de muchos chilenos es la
realidad de la población de más escasos
recursos todo está bien tico entonces
digo ya que voy a hacer que voy a hacer
mi mamá me dice no tranquila yo lo voy a
solucionar como buena mamá siempre
poniendo el hombro y creyendo entonces
un día llegue a mí si me la tengo la
cual sería vivir todos créditos en caja
de compensación alguien sabe lo que
significa pero con crédito me caso una
posición tenemos ahí para ir tres veces
o cuatro veces el crédito de bien vista
es la realidad de la gente de más
escasos recursos
partimos este proyecto con dos préstamos
que eran tres millones de pesos y dos
millones de pesos y digo que voy a
comprar el implemento empecé a buscar un
galpón donde arrendar etcétera etcétera
y na nace mi primer emprendimiento que
es olympique construcción un gimnasio
que hoy en día alberga más de 350
alumnos ya llevamos cinco años
trabajando en este proyecto y parto
solitos por dos solito como no tenía
mucho recurso y como no había cinco
millones ya que hacen maravillas
me tocó barrer me tocó pintar me tocó
limpiar todo tuve que hacer todo todo
todo para partir este emprendimiento que
la olympic construcción me tocaba
durante tres años tuve que barrer
recibir el dinero liberar créditos hacia
las clases y así me levantaba todos los
días a las siete la mañana hacia mis
primeros personalizados así que hace
todo el día al menos diez clases tenía
una hora para entrenar y hora al día
para comer y terminaba la once de la
noche de trabajar todos días de 7 a 11
de luna domingo el alumno del gimnasio
que hace clase los domingos y estaba
dispuesto todo porque para mí no era
malo sino que yo estaba luchando por mis
objetivos
yo estaba ganando la vida normalmente la
gente dice ok yo a un emprendimiento
porque voy a ganar mucho dinero no yo
estaba emprendiendo porque él estaba
sobreviviendo la vida tomé algo muy
pequeño y lo convertía en algo
medianamente pequeño y después más
pequeño y después lo que mediano y así
fue creciendo y resulta que olímpica
empezó a crecer a crecer a crecer a
crecer a crecer a crecer a los 20 años
me invitan a un programa que se llamaba
puesto por ti
tuve que sujetar dos autos jugué todo
esto y me ganó un millón setecientos mil
pesos imagínense a los 20 años ganarte
un millón 700 700 mil pesos por estar
viendo la tele
y el millón setecientos digo qué hago
con esto normalmente seamos sinceros
alguien de 21 años dice ok me voy a
carretear me voy de vacaciones hago lo
que quiero yo lo que hice fue tomar ese
millón setecientos mil pesos y lo
primero que hago al día siguiente llamó
a una importa agregó
mi primer reinversión olímpico un medio
700 implementos y cuando veo que llega a
este implemento al gimnasio mira digo y
la gente como es felicitado y el bien
marcelo qué bueno que estés pero jugando
de llevar el gimnasio etcétera y me digo
yo quiero más que esto no quiero
solamente esto este implemento quiero
hacer más cosas así que me puse en
campaña empezó a trabajar el doble y en
los 20 años hago mi primera importación
déjenselo ni siquiera la verdad no tenía
idea de lo que era un importación yo
solamente sabía que quería comprar cosas
en china porque me salía 50% más barato
llegó primera importación con 20 años
traje 10 toneladas de implemento y esas
10 toneladas de implemento
llegaron a chile y reímos nuevamente el
gimnasio lo miro si todavía no es
suficiente digo a los 21 hago mi segunda
importación pero aquí tuvo un problema
resulta que no sabía mucho de negocio yo
solamente sabía que hay que trabajar
duro ganar dinero reinvertir y seguir
así hasta que no sé cuándo voy a parar
es verdad tengo objetivos muy grandes
media entonces yo solamente sé que tengo
que trabajar y reinvertir pero resulta
que esta importación era eran si no me
equivoco como 16 millones de pesos que
tuve importar pero me pidió la máquina
alguien los que son emprendedores si hay
aquí sabes lo que significa eso entonces
me vio la máquina y no tenía cómo pagar
la última cuota de él
de este esta importación
y me acuerdo y estaba con mi polola en
ese momento no sabíamos qué hacer que
estaba la escalera de mi gimnasio y si
yo no pagaba así como en dos días cuatro
millones de pesos perdía toda mi
importación
todos estos 215 millones de implementos
y digo ok que hago que hago que hago que
hago que hago que juzgado
y mi polola grillo en mi y mi hijo tomás
sólo te paso 4 millones de pesos
cuánto corto y luego damos una semana y
aparte voy a quedar así
y resulta que sí pasó 24 bien eso me
llega a la importación tuve que ir a
chacabuco a buscar 20 toneladas
implemento cargarla yo yo mi valor a los
220 con la sola no habíamos pagado los 4
millones de veces que era costaba la
importación que ayer a la última contra
importación así que tuve que 20
toneladas cargarla del camión al
gimnasio toda una tarde en eso pero no
importa no me quejaba porque cuando
llegaron lo implantó el gimnasio toda la
gente habla audio y felicitaciones y
seguía creciendo el gimnasio siguen
creciendo nuestro capital y así así así
y resulta que olympique de la en cinco
años creció precio creció y la verdad yo
nunca me di cuenta cuánto creció porque
en paralelo también potencia mi carrera
deportiva yo me dedico profesionalmente
a competir en cloud fin
actualmente soy el número uno de
latinoamérica y en esto no pasó algo muy
parecido es como
le voy a mostrar una experiencia yo
estaba en eeuu en un mundial en miami y
el múltiple miami 30.000 personas tres
escenarios premios d
30 mil dólares creo que es ganaban el
que ganaba el campeonato y así y con
tipos que yo voy a por instalar así como
usted seguimos por instagram 5 500 mil
seguidores todos fanáticos de ellos
grabando le vio a nike a la marca de
suplementos y yo el chileno ahí al lado
de ello a la hora y de repente me
escuchan hablar español y me y me dicen
y me dicen
todas las español y el negocio y de
dónde eres de chile y dónde queda eso no
en suramérica no podían creer que un
chileno estuviera combinando al lado de
ello pero yo estaba ahí como buen
chileno siempre genera en todos lados en
el mundial de miami compitiendo así que
logre este objetivo que era deportivo
tu sponsor y may que personalmente a
estos 12 en paralelo hice estos juegos
como emprendimientos por separado uno
fue pueden ser olímpico y otro fue
potenciar mi carrera dentro de mi
carrera deportiva nos imaginamos cosas
que tuve va a ser me agarre tres veces
el pectoral me corte los dos tendones
rotulianos perdí 14 millón una era un
campeonato porque invertir todo mi
dinero en mi carrera deportiva y resulta
que me lesioné estuvo un año sin
competir y pasaron un montón de cosas
durante este año pero siempre mi motor
fue la pasión era como ya fui resiliente
no importa ok me pasó algo malo ya plan
de nuevo plan de acción siempre querido
los planes de acciones como logro pueden
ser mi carrera ahora es en mi negocio mi
negocio a solución a mi carrera mi
carrera va a darme mayor cantidad de
empoderamiento frente a la sociedad
deportiva y eso va a traer más alumnos y
así fui armando estrategias de marketing
de neuro ventas para poder hacer crecer
todo lo que yo quería hacer
entonces hasta ese momento
me moví a lo que significaba poder ser
deportista de alto rendimiento y estar
dentro de los mejores del mundo porque
yo no creía que por quién vive en
concepción no pudiera ser compitiendo
contra los estadounidenses
osea imagínense mi compañero
entrenamiento en eeuu yo parte varias
veces voy a eeuu entrenar y mi compañero
de entrenamiento es propicio por todas
las marcas él solamente sigue a entrenar
a nosotros en su audi todos los días le
están sacando fotos llegan al kiel y se
toman botellas y yo estaba ahí con la
escuchaba un amigo que hacía cayera y
dicho aquel entonces era mi único emisor
pero no importa en base a eso logré
quedar 14 del mundo en compró en
latinoamérica el mejor resultado
resultado de la historia en lo que
significa que 2 y en latinoamérica
esas mismas acciones en ese momento pero
resulta que un día
mi pasión cambio de objetivos de vida
cambiaron fue así cómo
venía un día venía caminando por
carreras ibas a tomarme un café a la
petrobras que estaría en tu cabello y
resulta que voy entrando y me veo como
un adicto a la pasta base y me dice
tenía una moneda y yo lo miro y les
prometo que entonces cuando venga bien
dinero tan grande trabajo porque yo
vengo de abajo de lo que yo sé lo que es
trabajar lo que no tener nada de vuelta
del destino
digo pero voy a ser distinto en ese
tiempo y estaba yendo a clase a niños
del sename de forma gratuita con un
proyecto nuestro gimnasio y le preguntó
hace cuánto que noto más y me dice dos
días y eso fue aquí una clave aquí y
aquí nos sentimos bien sé lo que
significa no comer en dos días alguna
usted es algo que no tenés para comer
o lo que es tener hambre
podría
eso y yo pero nunca me quejé pero dije
ok no comían dos días aunque no importa
luego vamos adentro y mira si no vamos a
strong boy the company se lo pasó ni
siquiera una ida y 1 miró y ya tomás
compro todo se lo más unido mira esto
esto no es solamente comida
lo miré elige y va para mí igual que tú
porque igual que los demás
yo diría ha sido como tú
pero no lo fue inculpada me está yendo
bien en la vida esto no es comida
compadre eligió esto en una oportunidad
como comer a la casa ducha te busca vean
lo que sea lo que sea pero trabaja y sal
de esta sal ganarle a la vida
compadre canal y la vida es más que esto
es más que ser adicto el tipo me voy yo
se puso a llorar
y si wood se lo prometo que ha sido la
mejor sensación que sentido medida y
descubrir realmente qué es lo que yo
quiero ser en la vida yo quiero ayudar a
los demás y así es como me obsesione con
ayudar a los demás empecé a estudiar
psicología mindfulness ciencia empezamos
a estudiar el efecto pigmalión a ver
cómo generar herramientas para poder
intervenir la sociedad y así es como
gracias a mi empresa método olympique
logramos hacer nuestro primer proyecto
social este primer proyecto social es un
proyecto de intervención ciudadana que
busca ayudar a adultos mayores
[Música]
y estos adultos mayores nos van a
visitar dos veces a la semana
tenemos programa de entrenamiento lo
evaluamos y lo estamos entrenando a 50
adultos mayores de construcción
entonces en este proyecto hoy en día
tiene 50 bonitos pero esperamos llegar a
200 hábitos de aquí un año
entonces
gracias a este proyecto yo dije
esta situación
mi pasión es ayudar a los demás mi voz
mi pasión es hacer un cambio mis metas y
objetivos son gigantes yo no me conformo
solamente con quedar olímpico a succión
no quiero solamente eso yo quiero abrir
olímpicos olímpico en todo chile porque
el inpec es una empresa social que busca
ayudar a los demás yo imagino esto de
aquí a 10 años tener un gimnasio
olímpica en cada ciudad interviniendo su
ciudad y ayudando a los demás en mi
gimnasio nosotros no te enseñamos a
entrenar nosotros enseñamos de valores
deportivos decíamos de disciplina te
enseñamos de comunidad de empoderamiento
de entender que frente a la vida no es
solamente pensar en verte bien sino que
es entrenar para sentirte mejor tú mismo
entonces yo les digo yo estaba destinado
hacer encuentro alto pero requiere mi
historia
cuál es para que ustedes quieran vivir
muchas gracias
[Música]